and leaked every piece of evidence that
they have
sorry has the prosecution leaked all of
the evidence that they had no no they
haven't so what they've leaked no they
haven't so what they've leaked is this
and so what we know about and then I'll
explain to what they've leaked so what
they what what we have is the witness
statement of the women right we have the
psych report do you think the
psychopod's acceptable uh I do yeah you
do why do you think it's acceptable
um it was done by professional what else
can I go by so you think it's acceptable
that a psych report was done on the U.S
moldovan woman and then based on that
psych report the psychologist made a
judgment that all the other women are
brainwashed so Jasmine and Beatrice she
never saw them she never met them she
never did a psychiatric report on them
and just based on them girls words she
decided that she they were very much do
you think that's how that's how that do
you think I don't know the extent to
which you can guess the other one why
have we moved on to the soccer part why
did we jump no could you ask for the
evidence that was the second evidence
well no I was asking you seem to be very
confidently stating that the presence of
the bottom [__] that that hasn't been
mentioned by any other woman that's
right another person that's right but
how do we know the prosecution isn't
planning on bringing that up at trial
well we could look we we only we only
base on things on what information we
have right now the information we have
right now is we know there's a witness
statement we know there's a psychopore
we have the two uh um rulings that were
leaked and we also have
um what else we have some of the some of
the whatsapps that were leaked
up I can't use you're telling me I can't
use any statement that Andrew Tate has
made in any of his videos or websites
that's not fair again for videos look
you you have to except look there could
be a Architects architect look I was
even going to do a lower below and I was
gonna I actually took a snippet from
your video where you said uh me and Lena
are racist but
guess what that was out of context that
was a joke you were making because you
were being humorous and it would there
was context because you were having a
joke with like somebody who's accusing
you sure what the point I'm trying to
make is that would be unacceptable for
me to use to then say you're racist so
in reality what will happen is this is
what I think this sorry this is in the
scenario where I think it should be used
and when it shouldn't be used so the
scenario where a video evidence should
be used is let's say for example someone
says I killed Michael and then you see
Michael dead you'd be like okay he said
I've killed Michael online and Michael's
dead but if he says I've killed Michael
but then like Tony is dead that doesn't
mean that just because he said he's
gonna murder someone that he's murdered
Tony so the issue is this whenever
you're going to use something online the
specific usage has to be used so when
you're giving the example of the bottom
[__]
you now there needs to be evidence that
that actually happened and there's no
evidence that that happened based on
everything presented with yeah that
we've been presented with so but we've
been present with significance so I've
done a significant amount of research on
the moldovan woman there's nothing about
a bomb [__] this I've done a second
amount of research on the U.S woman
there's nothing about a bottom [__]
um Jasmine and Beatrice the same thing
this you UK um this new woman number
seven the BBC did she literally says she
actually explains how she went abroad
and it was based on her own decision her
introduction with Andrew test so we've
got five women so yeah there is a small
possibility that the other two women
could say that happened but right now
based on these five women no okay so
when you compare the joke about me
making a small racist comment saying no
no you're saying this let's say even if
I did yeah right the way that you would
evaluate the truthfulness of it he said
well let's look at his entire body of
really work I accept it exactly so if
somebody's making comments about Andrew
Tate then we would look at his entire
body of work and so if we look at what
Andrew Tate's business is or at least
what he's claimed it is is he's working
with over 70 women and he claims most of
them are his girlfriends are loyal to
him a lot of them are Eastern European
um he has talked about defrauding them
on their taxes he's talked about using a
body a bottom [__] to rope some of them
into his business he's talked about how
his brother has talked about how he
doesn't let any of them read any of
their Instagram messages he's talked
about how he doesn't let any of them
leave there's been statements leaked by
some of the victims saying that they
weren't allowed to leave the premises
without a bodyguard or without one of
the two women going along with them that
when we look at all of this I don't
think it's fair to say that we're just
taking a single clip where we're just
taking one comment and we're trying to
make the claim like oh Andrew Tate is
this horrible person his entire model of
of caming from his brother talking about
how they would just scam men how oh here
you go
I gave you two yeah
there you go okay much appreciated we're
accommodating here yeah accommodating
Andrew Tate and Tristan Tate's entire
lives have been them openly talking
about how they are scammers and about
how they basically acquire women to use
for their businesses in ways that to any
sane person is going to sound like sex
trafficking well you're getting women
that are loyal and faithful to you that
you're going to get to do camming and in
multiple statements they've said like oh
and you know what they're my property
and I get all the money and then in
other statements uh Andrew is detailed
how he defrauds them on their taxes I
don't see how any insane person does
look at this guy like oh you know this
kind of looks like sex trafficking it
really does fit the bill completely so
okay so the basically two points the
fallacy of your position is this and
I'll get to the fallacy in a second
first things first
I agree with you you should take a
person's full body of information and
when you take Andrew Test full body you
have you've seen it online there's so
many of his fans have produced videos
demonstrating the complete opposite no
you shouldn't for all the women no you
should look after them you should take
care of them you should respect them so
on and so forth so you do have content
that is equally on the same level as the
content that you use to attack it and
that's my point when you use the whole
body there is a huge level of body of
information out there that shows both
the positivity of what he's doing and
the negativity of these statements
that's the first point in terms of the
second Point again you this is the
problem you're doing because I know you
have to do it because you know the case
doesn't line up with your point what
you're basically doing is separating
online content of what he's saying and
saying I don't care about what's
happening in the case that you should be
convicted based on that but guess what
I'm saying what he's saying online has
no correlation with what he's done so
therefore you can't use that as evidence
to then say he should be convicted what
you should be doing
and what you can do and I would find
that acceptable is if you did if he's
actually got a specific statement so
let's say the U.S woman says look he did
next to me specifically X naught the
whole thing and trying to make it look
like human trafficking and then you went
and found he did X in the video then you
could be like he did it but that's not
what's happening you're basically saying
he did this on the video I do not care
what the evidence did I'm gonna just say
that he's guilty so what you're
basically saying is guess what I'm gonna
trial him or I'm gonna convict him based
solely on social media content
irrespective of what the real life
content is and that's a problematic
because like I said you're not
understanding the point of and I try to
explain to you from uh think about when
you thought it was a relationship but
you're not understanding the issue of
this people talk
in in humor people don't always talk in
Little literalism People exaggerate
people uh try and make their business
look a lot better than they did there's
a number of reasons for that but that's
basically what happens so in reality
when you're saying this we need to look
at it from a contextual point of view so
that's the first point so now you what
you need to do is give me if you want
something as evidence give me something
in the documents something that they've
done that you say yeah they should be
convicted because guess what right now
the judge doesn't agree with you because
the judge said there's a reasonable
suspicion but there's not enough
evidence to prosecute and convict so
that's why the prosecutor for the last
nine months as well as these two months
is looking for the evidence because if
you add that if he had the evidence to
convict them or prosecute them even
before that he would have used it but he
knows that this social media content
that you're talking about that doesn't
match up with what the real life
evidence and claims of the women are so
what what you are saying is guess what
I don't care what the judge says it
doesn't matter that the judge says that
there's not enough evidence to prosecute
and convict
that's not good enough for me I'm going
to look at social media contact and he's
and he's guilty okay so I'll reiterate
what I said at the beginning of the show
um only one of us here seems interested
in having the process follow itself
completely and that's me I said that
whatever they find I think that if they
find enough to bring charges then they
should have a trial and if they do well
on their trial the prosecution then he
should get convicted that's how it
should work it might be the case that
after the prosecution digs further that
they don't fight enough and Andrew Tate
and Tristan and the other two women end
up walking that could be the case and if
that is the case then that's fine I'm
not here saying that he should be
convicted you keep saying that he should
be convicted I think that I don't
believe that he should be convicted
based on what he said in his social
media post thanks
um okay cool but yeah I think that's but
I think that it's I think that it's okay
so what do we disagree hold on hold on
well I'll tell you yeah the first thing
you said is look at his full body of
work okay his full body of work is that
he treats women like property when he
has some Tick Tock videos that say
things like you should look after women
and respect them and take care of them
he's taking care of them as a pimp takes
care of his prostitutes and he's
reiterated that multiple times that the
women belong to him that they're not
allowed to go out without him they can't
go to the club without him they can't do
these things without him that they stay
home all the time and they they cook and
they clean and they hold on let me
respond to his things please and then
you can say whatever okay okay yeah that
he's multiple times state of this and
his brother Tristan has stated the same
thing as well that they're not allowed
to look at their Instagram DMS that he
controls all of their social media
accounts he may probably control their
income as well I would imagine that
would extend to that so when you say
that there's a counterbalance while on
one end he's treating women like
property but on the other end he's
saying that respect them because you
need to own them as as sex workers
essentially or own them as house slaves
I don't think that that's a good
counterbalance you bring up this point
again and again he should be convicted
based on social media things I have not
said that he should be convicted what
I'm saying is that and what you agreed
to is that the prosecution hasn't given
us every single piece of evidence if
Andrew Tata said I defraud people on
their taxes I don't think that he should
be convicted for it I think that would
be a good point for the prosecution to
say okay well let's start subpoenaing
records and let's see what have these
girls actually been paid they should
have bank accounts there should be
income statements from his caming
websites and then the prosecution can
look and they could go this woman earned
you know 50 000 Romanian dollars and she
was paid you know 25 000 remaining
dollars well everything here is probably
good and they move on but maybe she
earned fifty thousand dollars and for
some reason she's only getting paid 500
Romanian dollars then that would be
probably something you would bring in
court and say hey look this is part of
the charges we're running against you
you are clearly defrauding these women I
don't know what the extent of that
investigation is going to be because
right now I don't have any insight into
what the prosecution has besides what
they've leaked to the public or
presented to the judge to maintain that
the tastes remain in prison until they
finish their investigation
um the people talk [__] humor and all
of this again I'm going by full length
videos that I've watched of Andrew and
Tristan Tate explaining how they work
with women and explaining their business
I'm not going by little equips I'm not
going by small Clips I'm not going by
jokes I'm just listening to how they
describe the process of what they do and
if you listen to it it sounds
indistinguishable from pimping
would you agree that the CCTV footage
should be included I don't know what the
particular I don't think that's weird
like why wouldn't they have that in
there well I don't know I don't know
what I don't know what evidence they
need to have on both sides because they
don't need every single piece of
evidence well I'm just thinking like if
you're gonna go off of because you know
you guys know a lot more about this than
I do but basically like they
that Andrew and Tristan were like
running this operation wouldn't CCTV put
footage be the perfect thing to see you
know like the promise I don't know if
the CCTV footage is just positive right
it might be the case that there are
videos of them partying inside but it
might be the case that believing the
compound is actually incredibly
difficult that you know that once you
step outside you get in trouble also um
according to Romanian criminal law
statements from victims um can't get rid
of sex trafficking like a victim can't
consent to that so even if a victim says
oh well you know this was all fine and
it was okay if text message logs are
released where he's saying like oh I
want to marry you blah blah and then she
comes down and she starts working for
him and she's not even getting paid her
Fair cut it doesn't matter if she comes
out on social media says oh no like
we're cool everything's fine especially
if they're still working in the industry
those statements explicitly called out
in Romanian law are not used to clear
the charges of sexual as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible